welcome back the miss america
organization is all about scholarships
networking making a difference in the
community and so much more and we are so
excited to have miss nevada heather
renner representing nevada in this
year's miss america competition she's
joining us here today heather thank you
for being here thank you so much for
having me well congratulations on the
title first off just how does it feel to
be representing nevada as miss nevada it
is an incredible honor so i'm actually a
third generation native nevadan
and so i grew up watching miss nevada
every year and i have so many miss
nevada's that i recognize now as my
peers and that is blowing my mind
because now uh you know the women that i
looked up to growing up are now my
friends and they're helping me get ready
for miss america yeah and you get to
follow in their footsteps and we were
talking a little bit before we started
this interview i have judged a few
pageants before i've hosted them i see
how much work goes into these pageants
alone leading up to it it's a lot of
work how are you prepping for the big
competition coming up in december a lot
of it is singing practice so talent is
50 of our preliminary score i'm a
theater major at unlv with a double
minor in political science and voice
performance so my talent is opera i love
opera i love musical theater and getting
to share that passion on stage is quite
an honor but it is a lot of work leading
up to it well and speaking of a lot of
work you do a lot of work in our
community you mentioned that you also
work with children tell us a little bit
about that yes i volunteer teaching
theater to kids because theater was the
tool that gave me my voice i didn't
think that i had anything meaningful to
contribute to the world until i started
at the performing arts and to be able to
share that message with kids and teach
them how to identify and communicate
their feelings and how to speak into a
microphone how to move on stage how to
speak in front of groups of their peers
that has been an incredible honor and
if you're a teacher out there who has a
group of kids that you would like me to
come teach theater to please let me know
well it's so incredible the platform
that you get from just being in the
pageant system i think some people don't
even realize or think it's just a beauty
competition and it's so much more to
that what would you say to people who
maybe aren't familiar with how
everything works i mean there really is
a lot that goes into it and a lot of
beneficial things that come out of it
absolutely uh to those people i would
say miss america has paid for my entire
college education thus far i've won 24
thousand dollars in scholarships since i
started competing about 10 years ago and
because of that i will be able to finish
my degree debt-free not a penny out of
my pocket so for people who say that you
know miss america isn't relevant anymore
while two-thirds of student debt holders
are women over two-thirds and so miss
america's mission of empowering women
with the gift of scholarship and
education is more important than ever
well that's incredible heather we are so
excited to see you compete in just a few
months and congratulations even on just
representing our state that's a huge
accomplishment but you're going to do
great we can't wait to follow along with
you thanks for being here